[Musique]
bonsoir le
heures
[Musique]
ouvert aujourd'hui
nous étions bien loin nous avions
entre deux pays
quand
avez-vous bien jouer avait pu bien
chanté avez-vous j'étais gentil et ça je
crois que quelques enfants ont été
depuis ton et chant aupa ton dos gestion
gens croyants
puisque l'eau entre si nous partons
petite fille
égard enfants
je seconde mais jamie de mes petites
filles et one
tu es trop gentil
essaye d'en nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils étaient
conduite de parfaits
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous allons aussi
inquiétés
bonsoir le
enfin on est bien
autant aujourd'hui au gallon temps
on va
les auteurs histoire
dur honneur 1
bizarre
bonne
maîtrise abily
[Musique]
qu'elle a
beau lui je retire
mes petits enfants chéris
[Musique]
non non ne vous levez pas je suis trop
content que vous suiviez mes conseils et
que vous vous coucher tôt même quand je
ne suis pas là c'est très bien c'est
pour te faire plaisir maintenant parce
qu'on pense à moi je pense tout le temps
à vous chica tu ne va aborder quelque
chose
je pense à vous mais je ne vous ai rien
apporté
allons
la g prend le
monde or mais vite le tas je reviendrai
demain
bonne nuit
quelle curieuse association tout ne
t'inquiète pas je lui parlerai demain
entre à ce drôle de nounours t'as raison
nicolas il faut pas te laisser faire
bonne nuit ma petite pimprenelle leur
bien nicolas
genaud
[Musique]
patron il était déjà couché le chef qui
ce que je suis content il m'écoute vous
savez il me coût d'un vieux nounours
route où loulou qu'est ce que tu dis
jeudi en août on engage bourse et bien
roudourou doux nom ce bonne nuit les
enfants à deux coureurs
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]